we start with breaking news right now
crews are working a fire in the Central
Valley Madison Kimbrough joins us live
from that scene with the latest tonight
Madison
active scene here is the Clark County
fire department and Las Vegas fire and
rescue are tending to this fire that
that's mostly contained as it's a free
alarm fire now this one seemed to have
started around three this afternoon
occurred at this vacant building that of
which we learned used to be a Kmart
Shopping Center plumes of smoke could be
seen across the Valley from McCloud and
Sahara there were several neighbors
around watching as traffic delays
continued and still remain Sahara Avenue
is still closed in both directions from
McLeod Street to Eastern Avenue as as of
now like I mentioned the fire seems to
be contained assuming that our weather
today really helped in putting out the
Flames but of course we'll keep it here
on 8 news now with the latest details as
we will keep you up to speed with the
latest information reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now